[Musique]
et
il était une fois un ancien peuple
nomade qu'on appelait les rajhi il
vivait dans la forêt
un peuple mystérieux il était réputé
pour chasser le miel mais andy cette
pratique disparu
il se serait alors tourné vers la
rivière pour tenter de m'éclairer un
petit groupe de pêcheurs m'a donné
rendez vous au fond de la nuit les pieds
dans l'eau nous les rajhi qui ne nous
reste plus que deux poissons alors on
mange du poisson
de nos jours c'est plus comme avant on
n'est plus tout seul dans la région
d'autres ethnies sont apparus et
maintenant la rivière se vide
du coup le poisson n'existe plus en
abondance et il nous faut trouver le
moyen de nous remplir l'estomac
autrement alors pour compenser nous
mettons davantage d'eau dans la soupe
chaque nouveau matin il n'arrive bien
vous à ces poissons disparaître et c'est
rajhi avec il ne resterait plus que 4000
tous sédentarisés seule une poignée
d'irréductibles continue à dériver de
temps à autre au rythme des éléments
quelques tentes et beaucoup d'espoirs
pour cueillir ce que vous donne la forêt
saisir ce que vous offre la rivière
[Musique]
un petit groupe d'une vingtaine de
membres prêts à résister et à
m'expliquer leur différence les sommes
rentrés de la pêche
le poisson est égorgée on prend ses
repères avec le soleil qui se lève et
l'étranger qui s'apprête à poser trop de
questions
ne reste plus qu à broyer le piment et a
évoqué cette rivière qu'on rajoute dans
la soupe
oh
[Musique]
la rivière nous donne du poisson cette
rivière nous donne aussi de l'ordre
malgré nos difficultés nous est toujours
à nous en sortir
par exemple quand on tombe on devrait
mourir noyé mais ce genre de mésaventure
n'arrive aux autres ethnies nous jusque
là ça ne nous est jamais arrivé même nos
enfants sont épargnés j'étais sur le
point de percer l'un des secrets
derradji quand les esprits de la rivière
se sont réveillés dans mon pays quand on
voit un serpent auront le dessus
est ce que c'est la même chose ici que
ici monsieur dit que quand on est
étranger à la nouvelle doit supplier ses
coutumes
nous les rajhi on veut dire le savent
pas c'est comme ça mon nom est rhamsin
rajhi 45 ans peut-être chez nous lâche
c'est important on connaît même l'heure
à laquelle on est invoquée aux années
moi je ne sais pas exactement monsieur
la naissance la mort vous savez nous
sommes se compliquer
je sentais qu avec les rajhi j'allais
devoir apprendre à me taire on ne montre
pas un nomade le bon sens de la marche
je m'attendais à pouvoir évoquer le
passé la chasse du miel aux mains voka
le présent
se disait pêcheurs il était en fait
chercheurs d'or pour un rajhi pas de
questions à se poser
quelle que soit la quête il suffit de
constituer une caravane et d'emboîter le
pas de la vie quoi qu'on puisse en tirer
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
un jour nous a dit que dans le temps nos
ancêtres cherchaient de l'or alors nous
sommes concertés entre rajhi s'est dit
que si l'on avait trouvé à l'époque il
n'y avait pas de raison pour que l'on
trouve pas aujourd'hui
à vos salades on à la rue avec la
tradition dans notre esprit on n'a
jamais pensé pouvoir se nourrir
seulement de métal précieux
naturellement ça pour tout le temps et
pour agrémenter le quotidien
[Applaudissements]
au moment où travaillent des champs on
donne un peu de repos j'étais allé sans
même qu'ils étaient il faut être honnête
ça nous permet surtout de changer d'air
c'est vrai que les travaux des champs
c'est bien mais j'aime surtout chercher
de l'or on est près de la rivière ça
nous permet de voir du pays
et puis au moins on est entre copines
puis ça nous permet aussi de nous
remplir un peu l'estomac d'un gramme
d'or on peut acheter jusqu'à 100 kg de
riz
ces jours là les rajhi avait décidé de
lever le camp pour un meilleur avenir
car la rivière n'avait livré que
quelques poussières gens croyaient ma
rencontre avec eux terminé mais leur
véritable trésor n'était pas d'or il
avait quelques pâtes et bien plus encore
on les grilles c'est bon ça le même goût
que les écrevisses tôt vers septembre
octobre
ils sont bien gras il a des pattes pour
marcher on peut nager comme un poisson
et même volé comme une abeille
c'est un peu comme nous il irradie de la
rivière et ceux de la forêt une légende
dit auparavant nous étions tous sur les
rives du lac de rares à un jour le lac
s'est réveillé à nous avons été emportés
par les flots
les rajhi a été partie certains sont
devenus pêcheurs et suivent le poisson
d'autres sont devenus chasseurs de miel
les suivent les abeilles qui elle-même
suivent les fleurs tu trouveras les
radis chasseurs de miel en aval de la
rivière
[Musique]
seul le temps permet de percer les
secrets je n'en crois pas mes oreilles
il existe donc encore des chasseurs de
miel j'abandonne les rajhi chercheurs
d'or à leur sort pour mac est de nectar
précieux
la fleur du kapokier me conduit à une
nouvelle branche de rajhi une femme et
quelques hommes la nouvelle caravane
mais pour eux
la rivière n'est qu'un chemin de
traverse leur véritable royaume et la
forêt
[Musique]
on
et ségo les grimpeurs de son état qui
ouvre la voie
moi c'est dans quelle direction aller
vers quel arbre nous diriger parce que
les abeilles ont leurs habitudes elles
reviennent toujours au même endroit ça
oui je me sens proche des abeilles elles
aussi elles nomadisent de fleurs en
fleurs et d'arbres en arbres
nous nous ne faisons que les suivre dans
leur itinérance une exigence agissiez de
nos destinées sont liés
après deux heures de marche on retrouve
enfin les abeilles une dizaine des
saints dans un même arbre on estime la
hauteur du premier à quinze mètres
tu vois celui qui est tout en haut
je vais tenter de le prendre en premier
il me faudra sept à huit minutes j'ai
appris tout ça en observant les anciens
quand j'étais petit je les suivais
partout et à fort que les regarder faire
un jour je me suis dit que j'étais très
et je me suis lancé
moi je suis un chasseur faire s'envoler
les abeilles et récolté leur miel
j'adore ça bien sûr ça m'ennuie d'aller
déranger les avanies c'était toujours
quelque chose quand on détruit la maison
des autres nous ne sommes pas des
braconniers c'est notre métier depuis la
nuit des temps
prenons que la sir qui contient de miel
nous ne touchons pas aulas nous autres
les rajhi cette attention fait partie de
notre identité nous sommes le peuple
tout le monde n'a pas la délicatesse
daradji vous pour monter pieds nus
épouser les formes de la nature volet
s'élance par l'arbre dakota est plus
simple à empoigner tout en tendresse
tout en douceur
dallas magicien dessine dans le seul
charme et d'en goûter les abeilles avec
un peu de fumée
et
[Musique]
en réalité il lui faudra à peine cinq
minutes pour rejoindre le premier est
sain
tous
m
angolais doit aller tout en haut de
l'arbre
je dois m'assurer de pouvoir lui
apporter toute l'assistance dont il a
besoin grâce à l'accord de voler les
[Musique]
envoyer un outil ou un nouvel en fumée
nous les rajhi sommes en vie ces petites
choses qui parlait maintenant notre pays
a un peu changé mais aussi sont en train
de changer
nous devons pouvoir continuer à ramasser
le miel c'est grâce à lui aussi que nous
sommes devenus des hommes
[Musique]
vous
oui
[Musique]
vous savez
tout le monde retient son souffle samba
nous ne percevons qu un bourdonnement
celui de l'étrange secret qu'entretient
gaulle et avec la reine des abeilles
ils prélèvent quelques rayons de cire
qui contiennent le miel l'élixir de vie
derradji quelques litres d'or pur à
peine
bien moins qu'il ya quelques années
auparavant le colza le javelot nier le
sale le capot qui et permettait aux
rajhi de grimper toute l'année
c'est depuis qu on désosse la forêt
depuis que les abeilles disparaissent
les rajhi manque de pratique au sol se
veut pourtant rassurant il n'y a pas
d'accident chez les rassurer nous
entretenons un bon rapport avec les
divinités de la forêt nous leur offrons
un peu de miel afin qu'elle empêche les
hommes de tomber voilà notre rapport à
la forêt divinité et aux arts c'est
l'histoire d'une compréhension mutuelle
les abeilles aussi nous comprenne ma
pauvre et sale c'est pour ça qu'elle
même des crèmes vous l'avez beaucoup
trop elles ne sont pas habituées à faire
du savon les un support c'est pour ça
qu'elle vous qu'on pense que nous
[Musique]
par contre
ces charges et simplement de l'odeur de
la forêt firent l'or et devenir pauvres
pour se contenter de miel se débarrasser
de l'inutile un doux rêve et golay vous
l'êtes encore me d'idées je ne fais pas
ça pour l'argent je prends des risques
ce qu'il vaut mieux tombé d'un arbre que
tomber dans l'oubli
les radiers survivront dans ma chute je
crois est un mauvais côté
peut-être que les autres noms conscience
de rien en moi
[Musique]
goldberg
oh
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
nous descendons tous du même arbre on
dit que du jour où l'abeille disparaîtra
quatre années suffiront elles à éteindre
l'humanité les rajhi seront les premiers
[Musique]